tag zusammen herzlich willkommen zur zdf
heute live teuren ihrem leid screen zu
aktuellen ereignissen und diskussionen
und diskutieren wir hier in deutschland
seit tagen über die frage ob der
impfstoff von bionic für menschen ab 12
jahre frei gegeben werden sollte oder
nicht die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde wird heute in
wenigen minuten ihre entscheidung
bekannt geben wir rechnen alle damit
dass es grünes licht geben wird für eine
impfung ab 12 jahren eu-weit aber in
deutschland ist die ständige
impfkommission skeptisch zumindest alle
öffentlichen äußerungen der letzten tage
gegen in die richtung dass man sagt du
die datenlage ist uns nicht groß genug
wir sind uns nicht sicher ob das risiko
nicht den nutzen übersteigt also ob es
nicht doch vielleicht ein bisschen zu
schwierig ist und wir würden gerne noch
etwas abwarten aber der
gesundheitsminister ist anderer meinung
und möchte trotzdem dass sich menschen
ab 12 wenn heute die genehmigung kommt
für eine impfung anmelden können in
absprache mit den ärzten und natürlich
eine entscheidung der eltern wenn wir
ins ausland gucken dann kam heute die
meldung dass in japan der impfstoff ab
12 zugelassen wurde das haupt der
zuständige ausschuss des
gesundheitsministeriums entschieden
der zeitliche rahmen den die
bundesregierung sich gesetzt hat für
eine impfung der soll weiter
festgehalten werden auch darüber werden
wir heute sprechen denn wir haben ja
weiter einen impfstoff knappheit und
wenn dann die zahlen gucken gibt es auch
schon erste umfragen zum beispiel von
dem meinungsforschungsinstitut sie war
im auftrag der augsburger allgemeinen
und dort wurde gesagt 40 prozent der
befragten erziehungsberechtigten würden
eine schutzimpfung für ihre kinder
ablehnen 51 prozent der befragten sind
für die impfung und der rest ist
unentschieden also viel diskussionsstoff
wir versuchen das heute weiter zu klären
die letzten tage haben schon darüber
gesprochen unter anderem werden wir
heute reden mit doktor christoph spinner
vom klinikum rechts der isar dort
pandemie beauftragter wir haben später
in der schalter janosch dahmen auch arzt
mitglied des deutschen bundestages für
bündnis 90 die grünen dort im
gesundheitsausschuss
und wir werden auch
sprechen heute noch mit der landesspitze
schülersprecherin vor schleswig holstein
haben wir die großen die natürlich auch
eine ganz eigene sicht auf die dinge hat
wir fangen aber an in münchen bei dr
christoph spinner vom klinikum rechts
der isar dort pandemie beauftragter
hallo dr spinner hallo schönen guten tag
herr becker aus als pandemie beauftragt
da geht meine erste frage in die
richtung sind kinder und jugendliche aus
ihrer sicht überhaupt die treiber der
pandemie oder nicht als ich glaube man
muss ja vor allem zwei aspekte
unterscheiden
kinder und jugendliche nehmen natürlich
genauso wie infektionsgeschehen das teil
wie erwachsene und darüber hatte ja erst
eine neuerliche studie der kollegen in
berlin auch noch einmal aufschluss
gegeben
gleichzeitig sind kinder und jugendliche
aber deutlich seltener von schwereren
verläufen gefährdet also bedeutet sie
erleiden zwar auch saß zwei infektionen
aber deutlich seltener kubik 19
erkrankungen was an sich erfreulich ist
und diese tatsache dass kinder zwar
gleich häufig erkranken oder infiziert
werden aber deutlich geringer
wahrscheinlich schwerere verläufe haben
ist jetzt auch in die diskussion mit
einzubringen ob kinder gleich wie
erwachsene geimpft werden sollten
das heißt sind sie dann für eine impfung
von kindern und jugendlichen ab 12 oder
würden sie sagen erst mal lieber die
erwachsenen impfen weil die vielleicht
ja eher einen schweren verlauf haben
könnten also bei impfungen gibt es aus
meiner sicht immer zwei aspekte zu
berücksichtigen einmal den individuellen
nutzen für den geimpften und auf der
anderen seite den positiven nutzen für
die gesellschaft
grundvoraussetzung ist dabei immer dass
impfstoffe sicher und wirksam sind und
darüber muss heute die europäische
zulassungsbehörde auch entscheiden ob
die durchgeführten studien bei kindern
und jugendlichen ab zwölf jahren genug
datengrundlage bilden das ein sicherer
und effektiver einsatz des kaiser
impfstoff ist hierbei kinder und
jugendlichen gegeben ist und nach allem
was wir heute wissen aus
pressemitteilungen scheint den so zu
sein und deshalb rechne ich jetzt auch
mit einer entsprechenden zulassung des
impfstoffes aber die stelle von oberst
kommission ist ja der meinung
das ist nicht genug daten gebe um zu
wissen ob das risiko den nutzen also
doch das nutze nichts das risiko
übersteigt was ist denn ihre position
diese frage muss man also auf der einen
seite ist die zulassung auf der anderen
seite dann der tatsächliche einsatz und
diese beiden dinge sind losgelöst
voneinander zu betrachten die stiko
hatte an dieser stelle ja auch die
aufgabe eine empfehlung im sinne der
öffentlichen gesundheit zu geben
und natürlich ist da ein war
nachvollziehbar das ist bislang nur
begrenzte erfahrungen aus den
zulassungsstudien mit den impfstoffen
bei kindern und jugendlichen gibt
erfreulicherweise gibt es überhaupt
keine hinweise dafür dass der impfstoff
bei kindern und jugendlichen nicht
sicher ist
die frage ist aber ob es zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt auch schon gerechtfertigt eine
allgemeine impfempfehlung auszusprechen
und es gibt am ende auch die möglichkeit
zu sagen
kinder und jugendliche die ein erhöhtes
individuelles risiko haben zum beispiel
weil sie vorerkrankungen haben die mit
schweren verläufen vergesellschaftet
sind co at 19
die können oder sollen geimpft werden
und alle anderen kinder ab zwölf könnten
sofern die zulassung gegeben ist die
erkämpft werden auch wenn die stiko
keine empfehlung dafür ausspricht also
ich glaube es geht hier dann um die
frage wie schnell und mit welcher
empfehlungs stärke sprechen wir eine
empfehlung bei kindern aus oder eben
nicht
die frage ist ja auch wie schnell geht
das mit dem impfstoffen überhaupt wie
viele haben wir gestern war impfgipfel
zwischen bund und ländern danach gab es
weitere diskussion andrea maurer hat das
ganze für uns mal zusammen gefasst nach
dem impfgipfel geht es vor allem darum
erwartungen zu dämpfen es wird keine
extra impfkampagne für kinder ab zwölf
geben jugendliche können ab dem siebten
juni nicht sofort freifläche gegen
korona geimpft werden
wir haben dafür keine zusätzlichen
impfstoff
das war glaube ich der entscheidende
punkt der in den letzten wochen
vielleicht das ein oder andere mal etwas
schief rübergekommen ist diese tatsache
dass wir jetzt die priorisierung
aufheben
ab dem 7 6 heißt nicht dass am 8.6
sozusagen diese die hälfte der
bevölkerung die bisher noch nicht
geimpft ist auch erste impfung hatte
dass die alle erbrachten sechsten sich
impfen lassen können der ärztepräsident
warnt vor einer frust welle in praxen
und impfzentren und stellt sich hinter
die stiko die noch keine impfempfehlung
für kinder aussprechen will
deshalb ist es richtig dass die ständige
impfkommission mit bedacht analysiert
wie groß die gefährdung der kinder durch
saas kopf zwei tatsächlich ist es sollte
jetzt auch kein politischer und
gesellschaftlicher druck ausgeübt werden
eltern zur impfung ihrer kinder zu
dringen dass eine impfung der kinder zum
indirekten zwang werden könnte dem
widerspricht die kanzlerin noch am abend
für die zwölf- bis 18-jährigen gilt der
sichere schulbetrieb ist unabhängig von
der frage zu betrachten
ob kinder geimpft sind oder nicht
gleiches gilt genügen hoffe dass ja
immer wieder gefragt wird für die frage
des urlaubs sowohl im europäischen
ausland als auch in deutschland ein
versprechen hat die kanzlerin erneuert
bis ende des sommers soll jeder bürger
jede bürgerin und alle kinder ab zwölf
jahren ein impfangebot erhalten
tja ob das klappt ist ein bisschen
fraglich ich habe hier schon kommentare
bei euch bei uns im stream von kirsten
zum beispiel die sagt ich habe heute zum
ersten mal seit wochen überhaupt mein
arzt erreicht einen impftermin zu
bekommen gleicht einem platz im
rettungsboot titanic zu ergattern das
wird noch krasser werden befürchten sie
dass auch herr doktor spinner wir leben
über am ende eine sehr unterschiedliche
situation während den einzelnen regionen
in deutschland sehr sehr gut gekämpft
werden kann und wie beispielsweise hier
in münchen fast jeder zweite bürger
bereits ein info angebot erhalten und
sogar die ersten impfungen erhalten hat
kenne ich berichte von vielen
patientinnen und patienten aus anderen
gebieten dass es sehr viel schwieriger
ist zugang zu ihm terminen zu erlangen
ich glaube positiv hervorzuheben ist es
in den letzten wochen gelungen ist viele
menschen mit einem info angebot
auszustatten
und ich bin zuversichtlich dass dies
auch die nächsten
wochen gelingen wird aber nach wie vor
bleibt eine gewisse impfstoff knappheit
und insofern kammern auch nicht
wegdiskutieren dass es nicht gelingen
wird in den nächsten zwei drei wochen
allen menschen ein akzeptables angebot
machen zu können was auch bleibt stellen
wir hier in unserem chat immer wieder
fest ist eine gewisse unsicherheit und
teilweise auch eine verunsicherung und
teilweise dann daraus hingehen tauch
falschinformationen ich habe jetzt mal
ein kommentar hier den würde ich ihnen
ganz gern noch mal vorlesen die impfung
hilft nicht gegen ansteckung und gegen
verbreitung für was soll die impfung
dann gut sein
stimmt das so herr doktor spinner nein
das stimmt so natürlich nichts die
profit 19 impfung trägt ganz erheblich
dazu bei dass sowohl die infektions
übertragung erheblich reduziert wie auch
der individuelle schutz vor schweren
kopf 19 verläuft und reduziert wird es
gibt der erste gerichte auch aus
deutschland das deutlich unter 0,1 der
geimpften tatsächlich saß cause 2
erkrankt und auch aus anderen ländern
wie israel und großbritannien wissen wir
also dort stehen im systematischen maße
daten zur verfügung dass die impfstoffe
weit über 90% infektions
wahrscheinlichkeit reduzieren und das
ist eine gute botschaft denn das
bedeutet die impfung ist ganz
entscheidend daran beteiligt die
pandemie einzudämmen
ich danke ihnen für ihre einschätzungen
für diese klarstellung die wir glaube
ich immer wieder wiederholen müssen weil
es eben doch immer noch viel
unsicherheit gibt viele nach münchen
vielen dank alles gute und wir schalten
weiter zu meiner kollegin anne gellinek
nach brüssel die für uns vor der
europäischen arzneimittelbehörde steht
mich das richtig sehe und andere gerade
kamen die meldungen eigentlich wollten
wir jetzt kurz vor 3 uhr kurz nach drei
die pressekonferenz angucken aber die
wurde verschoben
ja die pressekonferenz wurde von 15 uhr
auf 16.30 verschoben weil es tatsächlich
so ist dass die experten der
arzneimittelbehörde aus allen
mitgliedsstaaten dann gibt es noch
unabhängige experten
pharmakologen mediziner die da alle
zusammen sitzen und reden
die besprechen nicht nur das thema ob
die ob der biontech pfizer impfstoff für
jugendliche zwischen 12 und 15
zugelassen werden soll sondern die
besprechen auch noch jede menge andere
themen die mit impfen und coop 19 zu tun
haben und offenbar sind sie noch nicht
fertig und werden erst um 16.30 vor die
presse gehen
ich stehe übrigens nicht von der
europäischen arzneimittelagentur die ist
ja in amsterdam sondern ich bin in
brüssel er in der mitte des
europaviertels danke an der für die
klarstellung dass ist das geht auf meine
kappe
aber vielleicht kannst du es trotzdem
einmal erklären warum wird denn es nur
über den bayern tag impfstoff
entschieden warum nicht auch über die
anderen es wird über den wahlsonntag
impfstoff entschieden weil der der
einzige ist der bislang eine zulassung
für die impfung von kindern und
jugendlichen gestellt hat bei der ema
ist in studien eingereicht worden
daten medizinische daten klinische
studien und aufgrund der dieser daten
entscheiden jetzt die experten der ema
ob sie diese zulassung empfehlen wollen
oder nicht
das geht dann an die eu-kommission die
hier hinter mir ist und die eu
kommission wird dann meistens ein paar
stunden später
folgt sie der empfehlung der
europäischen arzneimittelbehörde und
lässt dann diesen impfstoff für die
impfung mit kinder und jugendlichen zu
diese eu kommission hat ja auch dafür
gesorgt dass die eu gemeinsam bestellt
hat die impfstoffe bei den verschiedenen
herstellern
da stellt sich jetzt die frage haben die
damals überhaupt auch die kinder schon
mitgedacht oder ist das jetzt gerade
erst aufgebaut
also ja und nein sie haben natürlich
impfstoffe bestellt für 450 millionen
eu-bürger da wären kinder jugendliche
kreise und babys mit drin
das heißt sie haben war als rechnungs
größe schon die gesamte bevölkerung der
eu als maß genommen aber die diskussion
darüber ob man kinder und jugendliche
impfen sollte die gibt es natürlich erst
seit 1
seit wenigen monaten nämlich seit die
impfkampagne in den eu-mitgliedsländern
angelaufen ist seit sie in fahrt
gekommen ist und seit eben ein großer
teil der älteren menschen und der
gefährdeten menschen geimpft ist und
seitdem wird man redet man auch in
europäischer auf europäischer ebene
darüber ob es sinnvoll ist kinder und
jugendliche zu impfen
genau das ist die frage bei uns wird ja
sehr hitzig diskutiert teilweise sehr
leidenschaftlich und emotional gerade
weil es um kinder geht wie ist denn das
in anderen europäischen staaten du hast
jetzt nicht alle im blick das sind ja
viele aber so die duh mit beobachtest
für uns was kannst du daraus beobachten
also ich habe jetzt keinen überblick
darüber wie speziell die diskussion bei
der impfkampagne bei kindern und
jugendlichen läuft aber was ich so ein
bisschen mit bekomme hier ist dass die
diskussion überhaupt über das
impfstoffen über die versorgung mit
impfstoffen über die organisation des
impfens dass die in den mitgliedsstaaten
ganz ganz unterschiedlich verläuft und
fast in allen mitgliedstaaten läuft sie
weniger hitzig und emotional als in
deutschland das scheint irgendwie ein
deutsches thema zu sein was die
deutschen wahnsinnig aufregt und
interessiert während zum beispiel in den
niederlanden die viel später angefangen
haben zu impfen erst ende januar die
diskussion ganz ruhig verliefen man
gesagt hat ja gut würde für impfen eben
ein bisschen später inzwischen haben sie
uns übrigens fast eingeholt also die
sind fast auf demselben stand auch in
belgien in dem land in dem ich erlebe
ist die diskussion viel sachlicher da
wird zwar mal gesagt
die flammen sind irgendwie langsamer als
die wallonen oder in der hauptstadt geht
schneller
aber das sind so diskussionen die fast
ganz ohne schuldzuweisung laufen nicht
so wie bei uns nach dem motto der
gesundheitsminister hat fehler gemacht
die kommission hat fehler gemacht alles
ist falsch gelaufen sondern hier wird er
so organisatorisch diskutiert ist es
jetzt richtig oder nicht aber es ist
nicht so emotional wie in deutschland
ist mein eindruck gut emotionen können
ja auch was positives sein dann sind
alle interessiert aber manchmal kann die
diskussion auch daneben gehen beobachten
wir hier im chat jedes mal an vielen
dank für die für den zwischenbericht und
dann gucken wir mal was um 1630 passiert
wenn dann tatsächlich die
pressekonferenz losgeht vielen tag nach
brüssel
jetzt sagt sie nicht mehr chips na ja so
ist das manchmal
wir schalten jetzt weiter nach berlin zu
janosch dahmen bundestagsabgeordneter
von bündnis 90/die grüne selber arzt war
bis vor kurzem noch an der vordersten
front tatsächlich der pandemie
bekämpfung der quit 19 bekämpfung und
sitzt jetzt im bundestag ist mitglied
des gesundheitsausschusses ich begrüße
sie hallo hallo schön und damals haben
wir gerade gehört die diskussion in den
europäischen ländern ist nicht ganz so
emotional wird nicht ganz so hitzig
geführt haben sie eine erklärung dafür
warum das bei uns dann doch teilweise
sehr hin und her geht ja ich glaube dass
natürlich einerseits nach all den
monaten nach der großen anzahl an
menschen die verstorben und schwer
erkrankt sind die nerven natürlich lang
liegen dass es auch so ist das in der
bevölkerung nach monaten in dem man
durchgehalten hat viele schutzmaßnahmen
mitgetragen hat natürlich auch das
verständnis für dinge die nicht gut
laufen für einen erwartungsmanagement
was versprechungen macht und dann nicht
halten kann
gesunken ist und die leute ein stück
weit eine perspektive haben wollen und
sich wünschen dass es endlich vorbei ist
haben wir vielleicht auch ein bisschen
zu hohe erwartungen teilweise hier dass
wir denken also politiker müssen sofort
mit der lösung an kommen wissenschaftler
müssen sofort wissen was los ist und
wenn es dann ein bisschen dauert oder
sich hinter widerspricht dass wir dann
sehr ungnädig werden
ja ich würde das den menschen im land
jetzt nicht vorwerfen sondern ich würde
schon sagen dass auch deutsche politik
hier fehler gemacht hat indem man sehr
schnell und immer wieder neuerlich den
menschen das licht am ende des tunnels
versprochen hat gesagt jetzt haben wir
die impfung jetzt haben wir schutzmasken
jetzt haben wir tests und damit wir uns
besser und es ist bald vorbei und ein
stück weit mehr ehrlichkeit die auch
manchmal heißen kann zu sagen wir wissen
es noch nicht ganz genau erst vorbei ist
und ob die einzelne maßnahme jetzt
wirklich bringt wäre besser gewesen also
beispielsweise ganz aktuell die
diskussion um kinder und jugendliche
hier ist es sicherlich besser den
menschen zu sagen wir haben im moment
noch nicht genügend impfstoff um alle
gleichzeitig ein angebot zu machen als
zu sagen es ist eben stoff für alle da
und dann festzustellen dass gar keine
zusätzlichen impfung impfstoffe
geliefert werden
die man den menschen dann auch wirklich
anbieten kann verspielen sie jetzt an
auch das versprechen von jens spahn oder
den plan von jens sparen 6,4 millionen
impfdosen zurückzuhalten für kinder und
jugendliche was dann gestern bei der
pressekonferenz quasi wieder einkassiert
wurde also das ist dann quasi nicht mehr
der fall gewesen weil gesagt wurde wir
haben einfach gar nicht genug impfstoff
was halten sie denn generell jetzt von
diesem vorpreschen des
gesundheitsministers der auch sagt war
es die ständige impfkommission empfiehlt
wird im zweifelsfalle für mich nicht
ganz so wichtig sein wir machen trotzdem
jedes angebot wenn die zulassung kommt
ja am ende des tages hat er ja selber da
ein widerspruch aufgemacht ja gar nicht
notwendig gewesen wäre also die ständige
impfkommission hat ja bisher erkennen
lassen dass sie vermutlich so
entscheiden wird dass sie weder
grundsätzlich von einer impfung abrät
noch dass sie grundsätzlich zu einer
impfung geld sondern gesagt hat kommt
auf den konkreten einzelfall also das
risiko profil eines einzelnen
jugendlichen und seines umfeldes an ob
man eine impfung im einzelfall empfiehlt
weil einfach die datengrundlage noch
nicht ausreicht um eine generelle
empfehlung zu machen und hätte ja
ausgereift wenn er dieses mal
aufgegriffen hätte zu sagen ich nehme
diese daten die empfehlungen der
wissenschaft ernst und sorge jetzt dafür
dass eltern dass jugendliche so beraten
und aufgeklärt werden dass sie sich dann
auch in die lage versetzt fühlen
letztlich eine verantwortungsvolle
entscheidung zu treffen stattdessen wird
vorgeprescht es werden versprechungen
gemacht dass jetzt impfdosen auch für
kinder und jugendliche ausreichend zur
verfügung stehen die nicht eingehalten
werden kann und die eigentlichen
aufgaben in aufklärung und transparenz
indem wissenschaftsbasierten kurs die
bleibt links liegen und dass das
sozusagen die emotionen hochkochen lässt
an der einen oder anderen stelle das
kann ich gut verstehen gibt es jetzt
auch äußerungen bei uns im chat von
astrid schäfer zum beispiel eine
versachlichte diskussion fuß aus
inhaltlich kompetenten äußerungen von
der politik unter presse das fehlt hier
und wenn man eine versachlichte
diskussion möchte müsste man halt auch
die daten die man dazu braucht erhoben
haben also da gibt es noch mal ganz
klare kritik daran dass es immer noch zu
wenig wissen gibt in den augen von
einigen ist das in ihren augen auch so
dass hier immer noch nicht genug
geforscht und nicht genug daten erhoben
werden
ja tatsächlich
kann ich diese kritik ausdrücklich nur
unterstreichen dass es vielerlei auch
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt in der pandemie
so dass deutsche wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler gezwungen sind auch
daten aus großbritannien beispielsweise
zurückzugreifen um die notwendigen
erkenntnisse zu liefern weil wir einfach
nicht die notwendigen informationen hier
selbst ergeben ganz besonders schlimm
und verteilt wir nicht beispielsweise
bei der angedachten oder jetzt geplanten
aufhebung der prioritätenliste wir haben
aktuell keine systematischen daten ob
alle risikopatienten in deutschland in
großer mehrheit geimpft sind oder nicht
und da aus einem bauchgefühl heraus in
der politik zu sagen es reicht jetzt
beheben die priorisierung liste auf ohne
zu wissen ob eben genug menschen
geschützt sind
das halte ich für fatal und das ist ein
gutes beispiel dafür dass wir in den
daten und fakten basierten handeln in
deutscher politik einfach besser werden
müssen wir haben hier gestern im
livestream eine muntere diskussion
geführt zwischen karl lauterbach spd
gesundheitsexperte und professor evers
die ist mitglied der ständigen
impfkommission und da haben wir mal zwei
kleine schnipsel rausgesucht die
klarmachen wie unterschiedlich hier
tatsächlich die sachlage oder auch die
einschätzung ist wir haben dann weniger
daten von kindern und jugendlichen
bisher und ein derartig kurzen vorlauf
dafür gar keine sicherheit staaten haben
und das finde ich eigentlich wenig und
darauf sind wir propagieren die größe
der studie die jetzt gemacht worden ist
die richtet sich danach wie groß muss
eine studie seien um ein klares ergebnis
zu bringen und somit war eine größere
studie überhaupt nicht zu rechtfertigen
weil das ergebnis war so eindeutig der
impfschutz war so stark dass nicht mehr
kinder in die also und jugendliche in
die also im studio hätten aufgenommen
werden können also der eine sagt die
studie ist eigentlich groß genug
zumindest so groß wie sie immer sein
sollte professor hunger sagt das reicht
uns nicht januar starben bündnis 90 die
grünen auf welcher seite würden sie sich
jetzt schlagen oder können sie sich
vielleicht erklären wie es zu diesem
distanz kommt ja im kern entscheidet die
ständige impfkommission ja einerseits
nach den sicherheitsdaten zu einem
medikament in dem falle eines
impfstoffes
andererseits auf der frage wie groß ist
das risiko eines einzelnen menschen in
dem fall jetzt von kindern und
jugendlichen durch eine erkrankung
schwere schäden oder gar den tod zu
erleiden und hier sind die daten die zur
verfügung stehen nach einschätzung der
ständigen impfkommission noch nicht
ausreichend ich will vielleicht
sozusagen an der stelle erklären dass
wir in deutschland mit dem gremium der
ständigen impfkommission sehr stark auf
den individuellen vorteil einer impfung
gucken das heißt also wie sehr
profitiert der einzelne jugendliche oder
die einzelnen einzelne jugendliche von
einer impfung und weniger was hat das
für effekte für die gesamte gesellschaft
auch für vielleicht das umfeld eines
kindes oder eines jugendlichen und an
der stelle sind andere nationale gremien
einfach auch stärker noch
epidemiologisch und aus public health
perspektive mit besetzten kommen
entsprechend auch zu anderen
einschätzung
es wird sozusagen zu den auswertungs
fragen dieser pandemie gehören wie wir
uns auch selber hier deutschland mit
unserer nationalen gremien zukünftig
aufstellen aber im moment finde ich
schon richtig dass man den gremien wie
wir haben auch zuhört und deren
empfehlung auch entsprechend
berücksichtigt und und aufmerksamkeit
schenkt das heißt aber wäre für sie
einen eine lektion aus dieser pandemie
und jetzt auch aus dieser aus diesem
streit zu sagen die ständige
impfkommission muss ein bisschen mehr
drauf gucken was wir die gesellschaft
gut ist und nicht aus das individuum
ich glaube es geht dabei nicht nur um
die ständige impfkommission sondern auch
weitere bundesbehörden und bundes
gremien institute die wir haben
die stärker interdisziplinäre
aufzustellen das muss sicherlich eine
wichtige erkenntnis sein wie wir aus
dieser partie mitnehmen um eben
unterschiedliche sachfragen mit
einzubeziehen das ist ja bei der
diskussion um die sicherheit von
astrazeneca von einer möglicherweise
seltene nebenwirkung im einzelfall und
den vorteilen für die gesamtgesellschaft
auf der anderen seite eine ähnliche
diskussion gewesen ich glaube das
sollten wir uns mit mehr ruhe mit mehr
zeit auch noch mal anschauen und daraus
auch lernen sie haben ja selber zwei
kinder her dann würden sie die ich
glaube wir sind noch nicht unter über
zwölf aber würden sie generell eltern
dazu raten jetzt ihre kinder impfen zu
lassen wenn es noch keine schweren also
wenn es keine schweren vorerkrankungen
gibt also meine kinder sind tatsächlich
noch sehr jung und kämen jetzt im fall
der erweiterung der zulassung nicht in
die altersgruppe die im moment zur
impfung ansteht
ich glaube was man im moment aufgrund
der verfügbaren wissenschaftlichen daten
sagen kann ist dass es einerseits bei
kindern die selbst vorerkrankung haben
oder die beispielsweise
geschwisterkinder oder im kindergarten
beziehungsweise in der schulklasse
kinder haben die entsprechende
vorerkrankungen haben aufgrund dieses
risiko profil schon sinn machen kann
impfung auch auf den bestehenden daten
zum vorteil des umfeldes und auch der
betroffenen kinder selbst durchzuführen
und hier wird in den nächsten wochen
noch eine ganze reihe an zusätzlichen
publikation mehr gewissheit und
sicherheit schaffen
fakt ist eins auf die ein oder anderen
andere art und weise wird entweder durch
die impfung oder durch die erkrankung in
den nächsten ein zwei jahren jeder von
uns mit diesem virus bzw mit einer
immunisierung vor diesen virus kontakt
haben ob wir wollen oder nicht und
insofern ist es auch realistisch und
wichtig sich mit den daten auseinander
zu setzen und hier im einzelfall
frühzeitig oder gegebenenfalls
nachgelagerten entsprechende
entscheidung zu treffen so kurze info
für alle die gerade erst dazu gekommen
sind wir hatten eigentlich gedacht dass
um 15 uhr oder kurz nach drei die
pressekonferenz der europäischen
arzneimittelbehörde los geht um zum
beispiel unter anderem die entscheidung
über die zulassung des bionic
impfstoffes kommen mir nati zu zu zu
verkünden
ab 12 das ist jetzt nicht der fall die
pressekonferenz ist auf 16 und 30
verschoben worden wir lassen den
livestream bei youtube offen dh ihr
könnt auch einfach euer tipp offen
lassen und warten bis es dann losgeht
ghana stammen ist noch gerade dabei uns
ich habe jetzt zwei fragen herr damen
ich weiß nicht ob sie die beantworten
können ich gebe trotzdem mal weiter wenn
man sie nicht beantworten kann ist das
keine schande
markus schmidt möchte oder hat behauptet
studie von bionic 78 prozent aller
geimpften kinder zeigen nebenwirkungen
ist das eine info die in bekannten also
im kern ist es so dass der impfstoff für
diese altersgruppe 12 bis 15 jahre um
diese erweiterung geht es ja im moment
ebenfalls
in erweiterung studien sich als sicher
erwiesen hat es ist ja so dass sowohl
bei jugendlichen als auch bei
erwachsenen so genannte impfreaktionen
insbesondere abgeschlagenheit fieber
kopfschmerzen in den ersten stunden und
tagen nach einer impfung durchaus häufig
vorkommen sie bilden sich aber
vollständig zurück darüber hinausgehende
schwere und langfristig anhaltende
schäden oder nebenwirkung sind mir nicht
bekannt
und dann gibt es hier eine frage von
silvio bankert wer haftet für
impfschäden an erwachsenen und sind die
kinder geimpft werden
grundsätzlich ist es so dass alles was
an schäden durch den impfstoff
theoretisch hervorgerufen werden kann da
haftet die bundesrepublik deutschland
für nicht nur jetzt im falle wenn es
generell empfohlen wird sondern
überhaupt wenn jemand eben geimpft wird
im einzelfall ist es darüber hinaus so
wenn also eine unsachgemäße handhabung
mit impfstoffen oder beim impfen ist
dann haftet auch die einzelnen ärzten
und der arzt mit dafür also im kern ist
es die bundesrepublik deutschland für
den impfstoff und für eine korrekte
durchführung eben die behandeln ärzte
oder der behandelnde arzt
damit waren bedanke ich mich dafür dass
sie uns hier zur verfügung gestellt er
sich zur verfügung gestellt haben so wie
uns die fragen beantwortet haben wir nie
gesagt hatten mit einem anderen ablauf
gerechnet so ist das bei live streams
und bei live-sendungen und eben auch mit
behörden die manchmal ein bisschen
länger brauchen wir haben gerade gehört
es dauert noch ein bisschen was die
entscheidung angeht wir lassen hier den
schleim problem besser da
wir lassen jetzt stehen für euch offen
und lass das halboffene ihr könnt euch
hier weiter unterhalten wenn ihr möchtet
ich bitte wie immer darum dass wir
sachlich bleibt und freundlich
untereinander alles andere werden wir
dann irgendwann löschen müssen wir
bleiben also mit unserem auge auch drauf
aber ich sage wir melden uns nachher
wieder in ungefähr nach stunde würde ich
sagen wenn wir genau wissen wann die
pressekonferenz los geht in diesem sinne
sei recht bis gleich
[Musik]
wir hören gerade nach den wir länger
gewartet haben das in amsterdam die
europäische arzneimittelbehörde vor die
kamera tritt für eine pressekonferenz
es wurde viel gesprochen unter anderem
aber die frage auf die wir hier in
deutschland alle warten wird der
biontech im stoff für menschen ab 12
freigegeben oder nicht und die
pressekonferenz live bereits wir hören
rheine der ausschuss hat sich für die
nutzung von community für junge die
jugendlichen kinder ausgesprochen
dr marco cavalleri ist für
gesamtstrategie der zuständige sweeney
leiter klinische studien und fertigung
und doch dagegen auf der leiter für
pharmakovigilanz wird sie am anfang
informieren über das cpp treffen heute
informieren und er wird sie auch über
die neuesten entwicklungen informieren
dann haben wir eine halbe stunde wo wir
noch fragen und beantworten können
während übertragung machen und alle
medien dürfen die es auf zeitung nutzen
und die entsprechenden links amt sehr in
der einladung bekommen ich gebe es ab an
den chef für biologische
gesundheitsgefahren und wegziehen
strategien dr
vielen dank danke dass sie sich die zeit
genommen haben zu dieser pressekonferenz
zu kommen
ich beginne heute mit den neuesten
nachrichten
sie erwartet worden
der wissenschaftsausschuss für
humanmedizin der ema hat heute die
nutzung der aktie von pfizer bahn zu
bestimmten namens kombinat für kinder
zwischen zwölf und 15 jahren und es gab
schon eine genehmigung für alle menschen
ab 16
und jetzt haben wir daten die zeigen
dass dieses wachsen auch sicher ist in
der altersgruppe 12 bis 15 jahre und
deswegen konnte der ausschuss dieser
entscheidung treffen und diese
entscheiden wird jetzt an die
europäische kommission weiter gegeben
die dann die letztendliche genehmigung
durchführen wird aber es dann liegt es
an jedem einzelnen mitgliedstaat zu
entscheiden ob und wann diese impfstoffe
bei junge wachsender zukunft genutzt
werden sollen
die erweiterung dieser effektiven
impfstoffe auf die jüngeren ist ein
wichtiger schritt deswegen halten wir
dies auch für einen ein großer leistung
die koordinaten vakzine wird hier auch
unter den gleichen bedingungen
freigegeben wie bei älteren also zwei
dosen werden benötigt mit einem
intervall von mindestens drei wochen
die wirksamkeit von partie in dieser
altersgruppe brot auf einem klinischen
studie mit 3000 anders enten und die
immunantworten in dieser gruppe sind
ähnlich oder sogar besser als bei jungen
erwachsenen
keines der kinder mit 19 wurde also
nicht infiziert vom virus ist gab 16
entwicklungen der kontrollgruppe nach
den zwei dosen des placebos die
19 bekamen diese daten zeigen dass diese
impfstoffe diese jungen jugendlichen
schützen kann vor der krankheit und wir
haben ergebnisse gesehen in dieser
gruppe die ähnlich waren die jungen
erwachsenen über 16
also keine sorgen die sicherheit der
impfstoff muss natürlich immer nach der
nebenbei gemacht werden das machen wir
auch durch das pharmakovigilanz system
der eu und durch untersuchungen die von
dem unternehmen durchgeführt werden und
auch der rub den europäischen behörden
als respekt ist wichtig da geht es
irgendwie die bedeutung eine größere
liefermenge an kometen 19 impfstoffen zu
bekommen für die entsprechenden in
kampanien wir arbeiten daran die
erweiterung der fertigungskapazitäten zu
genehmigen
um auch größere flexibilität zu bekommen
in der lage der impfstoffe das würde der
impfkampagne in europa helfen wir haben
eine 1 30 tage lagerungs zeit für die
erlaubt bei kühlschrank temperaturen so
dass man bei büchern temperaturen so
dass man dann größere freiheit hat und
wir wollen sicherstellen dass die
gesetzgebung weitersagen fertigungs orte
so schnell wie möglich geschieht unsere
neuesten
anstrengungen haben geholfen die
situation in europa zu verbessern und
die impfkampagnen zu beschleunigen
wir arbeiten auch mit impfstoff
entwicklern an möglichen booster dosen
um sicherzustellen dass die den besten
zeitrahmen angeht würde was die beste
strategie wäre wir haben vorläufige
daten wir warten noch auf weitere daten
die es in naher zukunft geben wird und
im moment scheint es nicht so zu sein
dass wir uns beeilen müssten mit einer
dritten dosis aber wir brauchen weitere
evidenz und die bekommen wir in den
nächsten wochen und monaten an
entscheidungen zu treffen
ich möchte auch etwas sagen über die
behandlung von kuwait 19
und wir schauen uns potentielle
behandlungen an
entsprechend den therapeutischen
strategien wie sie auch von der eu
kommission vorgeschlagen worden und wir
hoffen dass wir in der lage sein der
neuer therapeutika vor dem ende dieses
jahres genehmigen können es gibt vier
antivirale regionale antikörper die wir
uns anschauen und wir denken dass wir
mindestens einige dieser im dritten oder
vierten quartal dieses jahres bringen
können
und dazu gehört auch dass einer dieser
monoklonalen antikörper hat vor kurzem
eine wissenschaftliche meinung bekommen
für die notfall nutzung das heißt da
könnte etwas entwickelt werden fasst
schnell auch die dass der behandlung von
19 erleichtern könnte und alle
therapeutischer werden gerade überprüft
von der er mal und sie haben vielleicht
auch festgestellt dass für eine
erklärung abgeben
über die kosten jede und deren nutzung
moment gibt es keine ausreichende
evidenz zu unterziehen
diese
mittel bei patienten mit google 19 die
nicht im kreishaus sind und keine basen
brauchen obwohl diese studien noch keine
besonderen besorgnisse regeln gründe
zeigen können wir sagen dass es
möglicherweise in den frühen phasen von
coop 19 jungen geben könnte
gerade bei denjenigen die noch keine
beratung benötigen deswegen sagen wir
dass man diese mittel nicht benutzen
sollte bevor wir nicht weiteres wissen
vielen dank und jetzt fang der anbieter
fragerunde viel sagte cavalieri und
jetzt beantworten wir ihre frage wenn
sie eine frage stellen wollen
dann klicken sie auf die entsprechende
econa vielen dank für die erste frage
das geht ja um die entscheidung was das
bedeutet er für die welt sein zugang zu
impfstoffen sie etwas dazu sagen wir
dass sie jetzt zweimal geschieden haben
dass die dämmstoffe benutzt werden kann
aber viele ältere sind ja nicht geimpft
worden
wichtig ist zu sagen dass es tiroler die
rolle der ema ist die wissenschaftliche
evidenz zu bewerten und die für eine
wirksame und sichere nutzung von
impfstoffen sprechen bei verschiedenen
populationen und sich darüber zu äußern
unsere meinung entspricht die objektive
trends aus den studien oder anderen
tests oder quellen und wir machen das
dann als objektive referenz für
öffentliche gesundheitsbehörden
verfügbar die dann in den
mitgliedstaaten oder in anderen teilen
der welt entscheidungen treffen können
um deren programme weiterführen zu
können und dadurch natürlich auch die
prävalenz der bahn db und die
priorisierung bestimmter
bevölkerungsgruppen in den sendern umso
entsprechend di resta entscheidungen zu
treffen je nach verfügbarkeit der
entsprechenden impfstoffe um dann der
impfkampagne voranzutreiben wir haben
durch die rolle objektive
wissenschaftliche evidenz zu liefern die
man benutzen kann für die ich hier was
eigenen kampagnen danke das ist wohin
die nächste frage von möglichen bürger
von reuters
vielen dank ich hoffe sie können sich
auch hören
die verträglichkeit wäre gut gibt es bei
den jungen erwachsenen bei der post
enten gibt es da etwas das zu besonderer
vorsicht rät oder überwachung oder die
bilanz das über das hinausgeht
oder gibt es irgendwelche gründe um
anzunehmen dass es möglicherweise
verschiedene mechanismen gibt bei
kindern und jungen erwachsenen im
vergleich zu erwachsenen und denn unsere
erfahrung bei erwachsenen ist natürlich
länger als die begrenzte erfahrung mit
kindern
ja ich denke das sind erfahrungen
während des jahres und erfahrung
entspricht dem was wir bei jungen
erwachsenen und also es denn auch unter
ihr ziegen daten glaube ich nicht das
ist was anderes passieren wird in dieser
altersgruppe als das was wir bei jungen
erwachsenen aussehen wenn man mit den
altersgruppen runter geht dann ist es
dazu die auch wirklichkeit ist etwas
anderes passieren könnte und deswegen
werden wir die daten betrachten um zu
verstehen ob da ein unterschied ist den
man weiter untersuchen müsste ja für die
nächste frage kommt von maria lara wurde
aus amsterdam die wir haben es gerade
gehört wie erwartet empfiehlt den
impfstoff community von biotech weiser
für menschen ab 12 freizugeben in der eu
bei mir im studio ist jetzt meine
kollegin josef posch dr josef esch
ärztin und zdf kollegin was heißt das
jetzt dass die europäische
arzneimittelagentur oder behörde das
empfiehlt das das heißt da kommt noch
was nach europäischer ebene beschlossen
ist das ist allerdings auch erst mal
vorläufig eine empfehlung die der eu
kommission dann unterbreitet wird
das ist dann erst mal europaweit zwar
gesetzt aber was die einzelnen länder
dann damit anstellen ist noch mal auf
dem anderen ein papier also wir haben ja
in deutschland auch zusätzlich zur
adidas die die zulassung prüft auch bei
uns noch für die arzneimittelsicherheit
die prüfung das paul-ehrlich-institut
und dann natürlich die ständige
impfkommission am robert koch institut
die prüft in welcher indikationen dann
der impfstoff auch empfohlen wird und
diese empfehlung ist ganz ganz wichtig
dafür da sind ja die experten explizit
damit beauftragt zu prüfen
selbst wenn der impfstoff zugelassen ist
für welche indikation für welche
altersgruppe
wird auch der impfstoff entfallen gut da
kommt da ist herz gemacht den streit
punkt den wir hier auch im livestream
sowie ein paar tagen austragen also was
heißt das was die denn die ständige
impfkommission sich jetzt ein bisschen
ziert so wird es zumindest nach außen in
der kommunikation und den halt diesen
wirkstoff so sieht es zumindest aus
nicht komplett freigeben möchte für alle
menschen ab 12 weiß ich sagen die
datenlage fehlt ist eigentlich dann wenn
ich nicht richtig verstehen ganz
normaler sprit bei der ständigen
impfkommission dass ihr halt nicht sagt
okay gibt ihm sondern wir gucken erst
mal für wen das wichtig wäre ja aber das
kann man ja zb auch sehen in dem an der
grippe impfung zum beispiel da geht es
ja zugelassen
aber die ständige impfkommission gibt
eine entsprechende empfehlung aus zum
beispiel besondere für besonders für
ältere patienten oder für patienten mit
besonderen vorerkrankungen
das heißt es wird wenn ein impfstoff
zugelassen ist ist ja nicht per se
empfohlen für die gesamte population und
das ist ja auch die aufgabe der
ständigen impfkommission prüfen in
welchen fällen das tatsächlich auch
einen größeren nutzen ob für das
individuum für das kind hat und das ist
ja in dieser situation auch jetzt zu
erwarten dass die ständige
impfkommission sich in den nächsten
anderthalb zwei wochen dazu positioniert
was auch für die kinderärzte und
kinderärztin ganz ganz entscheidend ist
weil sonst herrscht natürlich eine große
unsicherheit bei den eltern auch bei den
bereitwilligen kindern ob sie sich
impfen lassen oder nicht
weil die ständige impfkommission auch
für andere infektionskrankheiten im
kindesalter eben ein ganz ganz wichtiger
baustein ist nach denen sich die
kinderärzte richten kann
würdest du dann sagen dass die
diskussion um diese ja dieses
fragezeichen der ständigen
impfkommission die halt gesagt haben
also für alle freigegeben oder für alle
empfehlen wollen wir nicht dass die
disney überzogen ist weil der unserer
wahrnehmung das dann so wirkt als ob man
den nicht verkämpfen sollte und du sagst
das einfach ja das machen die einfach
eigentlich immer dass sie sagen für den
und den willen wir empfehlen und für die
nicht so besonders
na ja es kommt immer ein bisschen auf
die die grunderkrankung natürlich
antwort der mann schützen möchte also
wenn man natürlich die nasa nimmt die
für kinder eine sehr sehr schwere
erkrankung sind und die auch potenziell
schwere folgeerkrankungen die auch
tödlich verlaufen können
wenn man davor schützen kann dann ist
die empfehlung sehr klar wenn wir jetzt
wo wir sehen dass insgesamt kinder ihr
sehr milde verläufe haben werden sie
erkranken und sehr wenige schwer
verlaufen und die die schwere verläufe
haben ihn zum großteil auch
vorerkrankungen haben dann ist es
natürlich eine nutzen-risiko-abwägung
dann ist es durchaus gerechtfertigt zu
fragen ist der nutzen hier
gerechtfertigt das kind zu impfen wenn
die grundlage auf der wir das
entscheiden noch nicht ausreichend ist
also ich könnte mir vorstellen dass die
stiko wenn sie jetzt zum beispiel eine
empfehlung aussprechen würde für kinder
mit chronischen vorerkrankungen die
wirklich ein hohes risiko haben einen
schweren kursverlauf zu haben zum
beispiel kinder mit angeborenen
herzerkrankungen oder kinder mit
mukoviszidose irgendwelche pulmonalen
also lungen vorerkrankungen dann ist
natürlich das risiko immens und dann ist
das risiko natürlich durch die impfung
deutlich geringer als das risiko ein
chor mit 19 zu erkranken
aber für die gesamtheit der gesunden
kinder ist das risiko der erkrankung
nach jetzigem stand eben überschaubar
sodass dann natürlich die abwägung ist
wenn die datenlage für den impfstoff
noch noch nicht ausreicht dass dann die
stiko eben mit so einer empfehlung
erstmal zurückhaltend ist die sie ja
auch gegebenenfalls nach weiteren daten
lagen im verlauf des jahres zum beispiel
revidieren kann und dann vielleicht eine
breitere empfehlung ausspricht oder
hatten wir gestern hier im stream
professor evers von der ständigen
impfkommission die so ein bisschen
gesagt hat usa und kanada impfen ja
jetzt schon menschen unter 16 zwischen
12 und 16 wir gucken mal was bei denen
rauskommt ist dann schon irgendwas
bekannt von irgendwelchen sagt der
mediziner so schön konter
kontraindikation kontraindikationen also
ich oder irgendwie nebenwirkungen dass
man sagt da lieber nicht oder ist könnte
hier etwas geben also kontraindikation
wäre ja erst mal wenn es definitv fakten
gebe die gegen eine impfung sprechen das
mag in einzelnen fällen bei
immunschwäche oder unter und einer
bestimmten immunsuppressiven therapie
dabei seien aber erst mal in person
spricht nichts gegen die impfung was du
jetzt angesprochen hatte was es für
risiken womöglich gäbe sind die daten
die wir bislang haben auch für die
zwölf- bis 15-jährigen so dass die
nebenwirkungen ähnlich sind wie bei den
erwachsenen beschrieben sind also vor
allen dingen bei kombinate eben lokale
reaktionen fieber oder schwerer arm oder
rot rötung an der einstichstelle
märz im block kopfschmerzen ganz genau
oder eben auch dass man sich sehr
schwach fühlt oder dass man irgendwie ja
auch muskelschmerzen hat das ein
normales freitags nachmittags gefühl
also na ja gut ich glaube bei manchen
patienten ist das tatsächlich durchaus
schwere aufgetreten
aber das sind so die nebenwirkungen die
wir sehen es gibt allerdings 22
erkrankungen die im verlauf nach der
impfung bei jüngeren erwachsenen
aufgetreten sind also vor allem in der
altersgruppe unter 30 die gehäuft
aufgetreten sind wo aber nicht klar ist
ob es einen zusammenhang mit der impfung
gibt das also sind entzündungen am
herzmuskel die die aufgetreten sind so
dass er bei einer also keine korrelation
daraus abzuleiten ist also dass man
nicht sicher sagen kann ja das wird auf
die impfung zurückzuführen sein
insofern das hat die immer auch in ihre
entscheidungen mit eingeschlossen das
wie es dass sie die eben sehen dass es
diese fälle im zusammenhang im
zeitlichen zusammenhang mit der impfung
gibt ob es einen kausalen also ein
wirklich begründeten zusammenhang mit
der impfung gibt ist eben noch nicht
erwiesen
und sie haben eben jetzt erstmal so
entschieden dass der nutzen dieses
potenzielle risiko oder eben andere
nebenwirkungen überwiegt so jetzt habe
ich ein paar fragen im stream also
einmal auch sehr skeptische nachfragen
von gaal kurz zeigen hier
andrea windiger wie rechtfertigt ihr
eine zulassung bei dieser katastrophalen
datenlage siehe pandemrix in
schweinegrippe also erstmal wir müssen
sich nicht rechtfertigen wir berichten
ja nur das ist eine entscheidung der
europäischen arzneimittelbehörde was die
stiko was macht werden wir dann sehen
pandemrix in der schweinegrippe kannst
du vielleicht das ganz kurz erklären das
ist auch ein impfstoff gewesen gegen die
schweinegrippe und dann gab es bei
manchen kindern und jugendlichen
unerfreuliche nebenwirkungen
ja also ohne jetzt gar nicht ganz so
sehr da rauszuholen ist es glaube ich
durchaus gerechtfertigt wenn man keine
langzeitstudien hat dass man vorsichtig
ist und dass man gerade bei kindern
jugendlichen gerade wenn sie eben
niedrig also ein niedriges risiko haben
für einen schweren verlauf dass man da
so lange wie möglich eben beobachtet und
daten sammelt bevor man eine empfehlung
abgibt dass die immer jetzt zugelassen
hat ist ist die eine seite
was wir jetzt aus deutscher sicht als
ständige impfkommission des
robert-koch-instituts daraus ableiten
oder eben sagen wir warten ab bis wir
weitere studien vorliegen haben bevor
wir eine weitere empfehlung aussprechen
das ist die andere sache gut aber dass
der gesundheitsminister jetzt sparen hat
ja schon gesagt wenn die imagion es
nicht gibt dann machen wir das in
deutschland auch ja das ist richtig dass
er hat da glaube ich auch dass etwas
revidiert natürlich ist das aus sagen
wir mal kinder ärztlicher sicht oder
insgesamt bisschen schwierig zu
beurteilen wenn wir natürlich explizit
eine von der bundesregierung beauftragte
institutionen haben die darin damit
beauftragt ist solche fragen zu klären
und eine medizinische expertise hat auch
das zu prüfen in welchen fällen eben
eine impfung empfohlen wird oder nicht
dann ist das etwas worüber wonach sich
eben auch die ärzte richten und was auch
ganz grundlegend ist für die für die
impf aufklärung in einem gespräch dass
man eben sagt ja wir haben die
kommission jetzt geprüft und in denen
den fällen ist das auch empfohlen
wenn sich die regierung darüber
hinwegsetzt dann über geht sie natürlich
auch diese institution dieser expertise
du bist ja selber auch kinderärzte wenn
ich richtig in der art in der ausbildung
also jetzt mal so sagen wir ich komme
mit meiner 12-jährigen tochter bei der
an
wir haben vielleicht noch kontakt zu
menschen die sind risiko haben aber
nicht so viel und ich sage einfach zu
wenn mir mir wäre wohler wenn die
geimpft werden würde was würdest du mir
jetzt als vater sagen
also ich würde dich erstmal darüber
aufklären dass wir sagen wir mal für die
kinder im moment einfach noch nicht die
datenlage haben die definitiv sämtliche
nebenwirkungen ausschließt oder die
langzeitfolgen auch ja ausschließt in
erster linie wüssten wir das für dich
und deine altersgruppe beziehungsweise
meinetwegen auch risikogruppen zu denen
ihr offenbar kontakt hättet ja auf jeden
fall priorisiert geimpft werden würden
so auch die indikation da wäre
und wahrscheinlich auch die
priorisierung aufgrund des alters und
weil ältere einfach schon eher geimpft
werden das ist ja auch das problem dass
kinder und jugendliche jetzt ja auch
nicht per se sofort dran wären auch in
dieser altersgruppe weil wir haben ja
keinen zusätzlichen impfstoff der uns
zur verfügung steht da würde er damals
in den großen kreis an lehrer die ganz
genau
das heißt dass die frage wann die
gesunden kinder also sagen wir mal dein
kind hat keine vorerkrankungen dann
reiht sich das kind natürlich erstmal in
die ganze gruppe der vorher
priorisierten patienten ein und wir
haben ja auf jeden fall noch sehr viele
patienten auch in höheren altersgruppen
oder mit der vorerkrankung die noch
nicht geimpft sind und das zu
priorisieren ist auf jeden fall
erforderlich bevor wir jetzt den
impfstoff an die jungen verteilen die
vielleicht gar kein hohes risiko haben
und wo die daten lagern noch nicht
ausreichend essen am 7 7 6
also nächste woche wird ja die
priorisierung fallen egal wie viele
menschen aus diesem trio gruppen jetzt
geht auch noch mal eine schwierige
diskussion
wir reden aber die ganze zeit immer über
junge menschen und reden seiten mit
ihnen und das wollen wir jetzt ändern
wir haben denn ist die post dazu gebeten
der ist landesschülersprecher in hessen
und kann uns jetzt hoffentlich hören
habe dennis sehr guter ja hallo was ist
denn so eure position ich meine es gibt
ja genau um eure altersgruppe 12 bis 16
ab 16 also die oberstufe darf sich
impfen lassen
aber dieser darunter nichts oder jetzt
vielleicht schon könnte jetzt nicht
impfen lassen was denkt ihr darüber
ja also ist natürlich erstmal
interessantes thema die frage ist eben
inwieweit man sich in unserem alter eben
ja impfen lassen möchte und aus welchen
gründen vor allem als ich meine habt die
expertise glaube ich wie alle anderen
aus dem internet und im fernsehen hatte
das ist das biologisch zu beurteilen
möchte ich mir gar nichts zu machen aber
was ich natürlich sagen kann ist wie es
aus unserer sicht einfach sich verhält
und da ist es eben so dass auch mal
warum gefragt hat natürlich auch die
rückmeldung bekommen
wie sieht sein hausrecht ich euch bitten
lassen warum möchtet ihr euch entlassen
da kam der fiat meldung ja ich würde
mich jetzt ganz gerne impfen lassen aber
daneben auch auf rückfrage nicht weil
ich mich dann sicher dass wir also wir
haben sie eben auch
so wirklich hoch ist das risiko in
meinem alltag gar nicht sondern weil man
einfach sagt ich möchte mein leben
wieder leben wie es vorher war
und da jetzt irgendwie ja diesen diesen
umstand zu haben
man kriegt das nur über eine impfung der
ich über die ich nicht sagen kann bei
der ich jetzt aber eben mitgenommen hat
vielleicht gibt es irgendwelche etwas
mit stören wo ich jetzt persönlich auch
nicht so viel lust hätte ist natürlich
die frage also werde ich finde den
kompromiss daneben für uns schwierig
dass man sagt okay geht bitte mal mit
obwohl das nicht genau wissen ich glaube
wer der deutlich bessere kompromiss wäre
frei zu sagen wir müssen jetzt wirklich
die leute mit gefahr für leib und leben
bei denen wir auch wissen was sache ist
erst mal komplett durch sagen dann aber
auch es ist uns bewusst dass ihre
jüngeren menschen nicht das hohe risiko
trag- und ihr dürft trotzdem unsere
öffnungs schritte miterleben und ihr
leben
trotzdem euer leben erst mal im leben
geht es eigentlich vorher war und wie
wird ja auch alle wiederhaben möchten
gestern hatte ich hier karl lauterbach
im gespräch der hat gesagt also er würde
es befürworten wenn es möglichst vielen
geimpft werden würden auch in der
betreffenden altersgruppe 12 bis 16
eben damit wir möglichst viele menschen
haben die sich nicht mehr anstecken
können und das betrifft da eben auch die
schulen mit dem hintergrund dann müssen
wir die schulen nicht nicht machen und
die kindergärten nicht nicht machen
jetzt drehen wir die schulen also das
ist er klingt ein bisschen so lasst euch
impfen dann können wir die schulen offen
lassen ist es für euch ein deal der dann
vielleicht oder aus seiner perspektive
der dann auch in ordnung ist oder
würdest du auch sagen also wir haben
keine größeren verläufe gesehen werden
nicht schwer krank wahrscheinlich also
finden wir es auch besser wenn die
schule öffnungen vielleicht länger oder
nicht so stark durchgesetzt werden die
den letzten monaten ja ich glaube den
schlechten spielen haben wir schon
hinter uns jetzt eigentlich nicht noch
ein also wenn man es jetzt anguckt 30
prozent der jugendlichen an psychischer
erkrankung ich bin persönlich der
meinung man hätte vielleicht an anderer
stelle härter reagieren müssen um die
schulen sowie so offen zu lassen weil
wir glaube ich eine gefahren gruppe für
ganz andere erkannten sind wie gesagt
psychischer erkrankung großes thema
jetzt aber eben zu sagen okay wir können
die schulen wieder weiter öffnen
wenn ihr euch impfen lass das ist
natürlich ein angebot wie gesagt ich
glaube man muss aber auch ganz einfach
sagen wenn wir an sieht die leute die
wirklich gefährdet sind betrifft
eigentlich gar nicht mehr und uns
betrifft seien eben auch nicht mehr weil
man weiß was ich jetzt wohl aus dem aus
dem fernsehen aus dem internet mitnehmen
wer geimpft ist der hat eigentlich kaum
noch ein erkrankungsrisiko bedeutet wenn
sich die krankheit unter denen also das
ist jetzt was ich immer mitgenommen aber
wenn es die krankheit unter denen
ausbreitet die eigentlich gar keine so
grosse gefahr haben klingt für mich
erstmal nicht schlimm ich weiß dann kam
doch teilweise okay dann können es
notieren das ist natürlich eine gefahr
dass muss man das vielleicht auch noch
mal sonntag diskutieren eine diskussion
da hatte ich dann wieder nicht mehr
teilnehmen könnte wie gesagt mir fehlt
die expertise im großen und ganzen geht
uns aber eben hat darum dass man sagt
okay wir haben tatsächlich vielleicht
nicht die ganz großen schweren verläufe
und man muss eben uns auch jetzt ja bei
dir doch ganz andere gefahren haben
trotzdem ein stück weit voran stellen
und man hat uns ja auch sehr sehr lange
sehr viel solidarität abverlangt und
jetzt an zu sagen gibt es halt trotzdem
nicht und es sehe er hier bleibt da wo
ihr seid und ihr stellt euch mal hinten
beim verladen und wohl wenn ihr geimpft
sein können wir die schule wieder öffnen
das ist einfach kein angebot und
solidarität ist keine einbahnstraße
josephine liegt hier die ganze zeit das
ist was das heißt du würde es ihnen in
dieser ansicht bestärken ja dass ich
wollte gerne ganz kurz darauf reagieren
dass das was du sagst ist ganz ganz
wichtig und das ist auch aus kinder
ärztlicher sicht ganz ganz entscheidend
da haben sich auch die hat sich auch zum
beispiel die deutsche gesellschaft für
kinder- und jugendpsychiatrische
infektiologie also die die sich mit den
infektionskrankheiten bei kindern
beschäftigen ganz klar auch positioniert
dass es darf nicht die impfung
voraussetzung für die soziale teilhabe
seien also sei es schule seines sport
sei es alle möglichen sozialen angebote
die ihr nutzt die ja auch ganz
wesentlich sind und du hast völlig recht
dass ihr schon genügend eingesteckt hat
während der pandemie und das sieht man
ja auch in der kinderheilkunde das dass
das auch folge folge folgen mit sich
bringt insofern wollte ich dich darin
unterstützen dass ich glaube nicht sie
die die idee sein kann dass die impfung
voraussetzung für all das ist sondern
dass die impfung eben in den
risikogruppen
ganz entscheidend ist dass man dann auch
bei den jüngeren altersklassen die
lockerungen mitgehen kann ganz ganz ganz
offensichtlich und wenn jetzt das umfeld
die l
großeltern oder risiko konstellationen
in der familie geimpft sind
dann ist natürlich auch das
erkrankungsrisiko den kindern deutlich
geringer
also da sind da hast du da hast du
richtig wichtigen punkt gemacht und ich
wollte nur ganz kurz ein haken von wegen
herzmuskelentzündung das ist nur eine
eine beobachtung das ist kein
zusammenhang und es ist einfach noch
nicht klar
das ist einfach nur ich wollte dass nur
sie und richtigstellen dass es jetzt
keine definitiven nebenwirkung ist es
ist einfach nur die datenlage noch nicht
ganz ausreichend in der in der
altersklasse
aber du hast ganz wichtigen punkt
gemacht und soziale teilhabe und schule
und hoffnungen darf nicht von der
impfung abhängen und das ist auch eine
wichtige forderung aus der kinder
ärzteschaft
ich habe ja so ein etwas ironischen
kommentar von world of tanks schulen
sind sicher weil innenraum keine aero
sohle dicht besetzt stundenlang ohne
lüftung also der hörig unzufriedenheit
denn ist wie ist denn das aus ihrer
perspektive du bist ja auch mit anderen
landes schulsprechern sicher gut
vernetzt und tauscht euch aus habt ihr
das gefühl dass euch die politik den
letzten monaten gut im blick hatte
ja ich glaube grundsätzlich ist
tatsächlich ist einmal jugendarbeit auch
platt sv arbeit schon etwas mehr in den
fokus gerückt was wir natürlich
grundsätzlich begrüßen
es war aber auch oft so dass wir eben
auch die politik auch ins eingegangen
ist wenn unsere forderung neben gepasst
hat wie das so oft ist und wenn es nicht
dann halt auch eben wieder nicht mehr
deswegen ist haben wir uns teilweise
auch ein bisschen mit spielball gefühlt
er halt immer anfang angeschoben wurde
wenn es gut aussah und wenn nicht dann
merkt keiner was natürlich nicht nicht
der punkt ist also was wir auch nicht
wollen logischerweise licht und ja auch
eigentlich kein umgang mit uns die wir
schon gar nicht wählen gehen dürfen und
dann auch noch unsere meinung nach zu
tun ist keine schöne situation und da
freut sich natürlich gab es auch keiner
darüber zumindest könnte jetzt eventuell
wählen ob ihr euch nicht doch impfen
lassen möchte aber in rücksprache mit
den eltern befürchtet oder das war so
ein bisschen meine befürchtungen ehrlich
gesagt abendliche auseinandersetzungen
am abendbrottisch wenn jemand sagt ich
will aber weil ich möchte mich wieder
frei bewegen können und die eltern sagen
die ist mir zu riskant das lassen wir ja
ich denke es wird vielerorts passieren
wie gesagt das ist natürlich auch die
diskussion von eben
inwieweit ist soziale teilhabe dann auch
eine frage der impfung ist eine
schwierige frage ich glaube das muss
dann auch jeder für sich beurteilen wir
sind natürlich ja der auffassung dass
man da den kindern und jugendlichen doch
ein stück mehr entscheidungsfreiheit
vielleicht auch einräumen soll
gerade wirklich die eltern angesprochen
kinder wissen dass dann doch deutlich
besser für sich selbst als wenn man es
ihm vielleicht zutrauen möchte deswegen
das ist dann natürlich der familie ein
fall der familie fall von der großen
politik ein bisschen weiter entfernt im
rahmen der großen politik kann man
natürlich können wir sagen wir würden es
eben ja so bevorzugen dass man sagt okay
wir schützen erst mal alle die wirklich
keine wir erstmal die brust gefahr haben
und man nimmt uns dann eben mit
und dann sind wir auch damit
einverstanden nachrangig daran zu kommen
und dann hat er auch wieder seine in
freier entscheidung zu treffen
wenn man das jetzt eben so handhabt dass
man sagt okay wir müssen wir gucken und
die schulen haben vielleicht doch ein
risiko und wir testen
da wird wir testen halt und wenn ein
fall positiv ist muss die ganze schule
wieder schließen
das ist natürlich was sehr sehr
schwieriges ich glaube auch grad da wenn
man dann weiß der impfschutz noch weiter
auch bad in den gefährdeten gruppen dass
man da vielleicht ein bisschen
individueller gucken kann
die quarantäne kreise bisschen kleiner
erfasst und da eben wirklich auch in der
richtung auf uns zugeht weil aktuell
stehen wir halt zweimal hinten und
doppelt schlecht ist einfach ein guter
deal da muss man es eben auch
entgegenkommen hast du dich schon
entschlossen und mit deinen eltern
geredet wie das bei der jetzt aussieht
oder bist du dann auch in der
findungsphase
bei mir ist es tatsächlich der fall dass
ich sag mal meine altersgruppe
da ist ja noch die bedingung ist leider
verloren habe meine eltern sind beide
kann gesund meine oma ist zwar hilft
aber ich habe nur noch eine hommage ist
aber bedauerlicherweise ansonsten nicht
in irgendeiner gruppe dass ich mich da
anstellen könnte das heißt für mich
stellt die frage jetzt erst mal gar
nicht mein hausarzt priorisiert auch
nach wie vor
und dann würde ich aber sagen sie
ziemlich auch so aus dass ich da noch
mal intensiv darüber nachdenken würde
mit der tendenz vielleicht ist doch wenn
das dann vielen dank für deine
einschätzungen und deine antworten
ich habe noch ein paar fragen an dich
josephine hier im stream
gucken da für sie beantworten können
also müssen wir ganz klar sagen wir
können nicht alles beantworten das ist
ein großes schwieriges feld einmal
tatsächlich ja ganz einfach die frage
von anna-lena nehmen wir nicht den
älteren den impfstoff weg wenn wir jetzt
impfen lassen gewisser weise ja also die
idee in ein höheres risiko haben sollten
auch weiter priorisiert erst mal geimpft
werden
das ist durchaus eine überlegung die
auch auch von ärztlicher seite immer
diskutiert wird dass diejenigen die ein
hohes risiko haben sehr frage von
anna-lena die ist sehr wissbegierig wie
ist die redaktion der möglichen
impfschäden und der möglichen corona
schäden für gesunde kinder also ich weiß
noch dass überhaupt schon das kann man
glaube ich tatsächlich noch nicht sagen
also die die schäden an corona zu accra
also folgeerkrankung von corona
mitzunehmen sind eher gering es gab auch
also ein entzündliches syndrom nach
einer krone erkrankung
wo aber jetzt auch sechs monate nach
untersuchungen die die meisten kinder
keine vorerkrankungen haben es ist ja
eine punkt aber diese die auf der
anderen seite haben wir natürlich eine
impfung wo wir im moment davon ausgehen
die daten die wir haben zeigen keine
großen risiken
die gruppe ist nicht groß gewesen und
die daten sind natürlich auch keine
langzeit follow up studie
insofern ist haben wir da natürlich
einfach nicht begrenzt noch ein
begrenztes wissen ich glaube so richtig
ins verhältnis setzen kann man es nicht
dann eine frage ganz pragmatisch von
enten ab wann können sich jugendliche
beim arzt melden und sich impfen lassen
das müsste dann ja auch quasi nächste
woche sein
ich meine zumindest haben wir ab dem
siebten juni die aufgabe der impf
priorisierung und wenn die immer jetzt
die zulassung an die eu kommission
weiter gibt also als empfehlung
dann könnte es durchaus sei also dann
ist der impfstoff zugelassen das heißt
eine empfehlung würde die ständige
impfkommission aussprechen vielleicht
haben wir das vor dem siebten vielleicht
aber auch nicht
das heißt bis dahin ist es erstmal
ermessensfrage und aufklärungs sache im
aufklärungsgespräch zwischen eltern kind
und behandelndem arzt auf der anderen
seite
werden wir auch was ab den siebten juni
jetzt nicht unmengen mehr impfstoff
haben dass das dass sich die frage
stellt das jetzt jeder nach dem siebten
impfangebot bekommt insofern vielleicht
bleibt ja auch einfach noch etwas zeit
die daten zu prüfen bevor wir überhaupt
in die verlegenheit kommen zu viel zu
verändern aber melden kann man sich wenn
man möchte und wenn es jeweils das
system zulässt also das ist ja auch
unterschiedlich habe ich festgestellt
zum beispiel ich habe es in hamburg
ausprobiert im zentrum da musst du immer
gucken ob ein termin frei ist in
rheinland-pfalz kannst du dich eintragen
lassen eine liste und kriegst du
irgendwann einen termin oder auch nicht
also das ist ja auch sehr
unterschiedlich das ist ja auch in den
ländern unterschiedlich gehandhabt nur
kinder geimpft werden sollen also
teilweise in impfzentren oder abbyy
kinderärzte das ist aber alles noch
nicht wirklich spruchreif
also dann müssen wir noch ein bisschen
gedulden und schauen was da tatsächlich
passiert ich schaue mal genau eine frage
von sven auf facebook wird es bei
kindern und jugendlichen auch eine
priorisierung bei den besonders kranken
geben oder ist das nicht notwendig also
ja es wird sicherlich an der davon gehe
ich aus dass die stiko empfehlung
ausspricht für besonders gefährdete
kinder also sagen die kinder mit nach
einer herztransplantation
lebertransplantation oder kinder mit
angeborenen herzfehlern oder lungen
vorerkrankungen
die werden sicherlich priorisiert und
gesunde kinder die im ein deutlich
geringeres risiko haben sind dann
natürlich nachrangig erstmal dran
so jetzt in der frage die ist schwierig
zu beantworten finde ich aber die kommt
immer wieder stelle ich fest setzten
sozialen netzwerken wäre es nicht
sinnvoller gerade über 60 also ältere
nur mit astrazeneca und johnson &
johnson zu impfen
weil es ja bei astrazeneca wieder
erinnern uns eben diese komplikationen
gab bei jüngeren frauen also ist das was
man jetzt sagen müsste wo ältere leute
aussuchen dürfen sondern die kriegen hat
nur noch diese beiden impfstoffe also in
erster linie ist das eine politische
entscheidung
wer welchen impfstoff bekommen darf und
natürlich ist es so dass werden wir
kombinate von beyond erstmal einzigen
impfstoff für die jüngeren
bevölkerungsgruppe haben ist das
natürlich auch der impfstoff den wir in
der klasse auch nur für impfen können
und astrazeneca ist das für mich zu
gelassen und man kann sich ja trotzdem
melden und sagen ich bin trotzdem
astrazeneca bei den älteren meister wir
bei den jüngeren bei den jüngeren jahr
sicher sicher ich meine nur für die für
die junge altersgruppe jetzt wir haben
natürlich auch noch weitere studien
müssen also 12 bis 16 kriegt nur bei
montech warten aber nicht anders und die
die ab 16 jährigen die könnten ja auch
einen einen vektor impfstoff kriegen
aber da ist immer die frage ist das eine
gute idee und dann ist die frage ja
womit kämpfen wir die eltern die eltern
ja also wie gesagt das ist natürlich
jeder hat natürlich das recht zu
entscheiden welchen impfstoff er nimmt
oder nicht also wie ob er sagt ich ja
ich nehme astrazeneca oder ob er sagte
ich warte bis ich in bayern tag
impfstoff angebot bekomme also das per
se zu beschließen welche welche
altersgruppe aber welchen impfstoff
bekäme das wäre eine politische
entscheidung und dies ja aktuell jetzt
nicht im moment im diskurs natürlich ist
es so dass der björn czech impfstoff
wenn der auch der einzige ist für die
jüngere altersgruppe der zugelassen ist
natürlich dann noch rarer und umkämpft
da ist aber es ist auch der impfstoff
den wir im moment am meisten zur
verfügung sodass sind viele fragen
gewesen wir haben versucht die zu
beantworten
wir beantworten können viele sachen sind
eben gerade bei dieser altersgruppe
zurück des 16 noch sehr im vagen im
unklaren
da hoffen wir dass es die nächsten
wochen und monate ein bisschen mehr
klarheit gibt josef in vielen dank dass
du heute nachmittag für uns zeit hat ist
und wir fassen jetzt noch mal die
beschlüsse und den verlauf des tages
zusammen das hat die kollegin julia
schröter für uns gemacht
kanada schon seit einigen wochen geht
kommt nun auch in der eu die europäische
arzneimittelagentur ema hat ja gesagt
zum corona im stoff von beyond
eckpfeiler für kinder und jugendliche
der impfstoff ist schon zugelassen für
alle ab 16
jetzt haben wir daten die zeigen dass
der impfstoff auch für die altersgruppe
der zwölf- bis 15-jährigen sicher ist
laut studiendaten ist der impfstoff bei
teenagern zu 100 prozent wirksam und hat
nur geringe nebenwirkungen die zahl der
geimpften kinder in der zulassungsstudie
ist mit rund 1.100 sehr klein für die
ständige impfkommission zu klein um
sofort eine empfehlung auszusprechen
die seltene komplikationen entdeckt man
immer erst wenn man größere mengen impft
und da sind so noch nicht die usa hat
jetzt damit angefangen und wir warten im
prinzip aus daten aus der anwendung in
usa wir müssen bei kindern vorsichtiger
sein weil sich noch ein sehr langes
leben vor sich haben und es gibt
durchaus impfkomplikationen die das
ganze leben lang wirksam bleiben können
trotzdem hat die regierung bereits
gestern angekündigt dass sich ab dem
siebten juni alle jugendlichen um einen
impftermin bemühen können
viele eltern sind verunsichert
kinderärzte bekommen das in den praxen
zu spüren
wir werden eltern natürlich so beraten
dass wir die impfung möglichst nur mit
einer stiko empfehlung durchführen
können und bei ganz seltenen
ausnahmefällen werden wir das auch ohne
tun
aber dafür muss dann auch ein wirklich
wichtiger grund vorliegen
die impfkommission will nun weiter
beraten eine empfehlung ob für alle
jugendlichen oder nur für
risikopatienten soll es frühestens in
einer woche geben wir genau wissen was
sie in deutschland empfohlen wird klar
ist auf jeden fall
der bundesgesundheitsminister möchte
trotzdem allen menschen ab 12 1
impfangebot bis ende august gemacht
haben ob das was wird werden wir für
euch beobachten genau wie die weitere
entwicklung für heute machen sagt cover
zu und sagen vielen dank fürs zuschauen
für das kommentieren und fragen stellen
die immer bis zum nächsten mal macht gut
und wisse